Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a ton of time
on this, but Joe Rogan seems to sort of have
crossed the Rubicon in some sense where Joe
Rogan has always been interested in conspiracy
theories. I also am interested in them. Joe
Rogan seems to believe in more than I do,
but there's a difference in what I'm going
to play for you today, and something like
the moon landing was faked. Joe Rogan's new
idea is that there is a concerted effort
to restrict access to monoclonal antibodies so
that people will get vaccinated so that Big Pharma
will make money. I'm going to explain to you why
this makes no sense, but this is now over the line
into something that is truly quite dangerous.
Speaker 4: Here's a thing I'm going to say
this because it's true because I've experienced it
many, many times with many people that I'm friends
with. They're withholding monoclonal antibodies.
They're trying to stop people from getting them.
There's not a. Shortage of monoclonal antibodies
that do monoclonal antibodies, kills COVID like
raid kills roaches, when you get shot, you get
it after you get you get COVID, then you get
this. That's what you gave Trump, and that's what
they gave me. Mm hmm. I got I got better quick.
I got better and Trump got better. Pretty
quick, pretty quick. And he's old and fair.
He's all that bad. And he got better in
four days. So why are they withholding it?
Because they want you to get vaccinated?
That's what I think. I think they don't want
there to be a very clear path where you don't
have to be vaccinated, but if you get sick,
you're going to be fine. So, so or is it just
the money going into the pharmaceutical companies
that's driving people to want everyone to
get vaccinated or must have an influence?
It's also the narrative. There's also people that
have been vaccinated that don't want people to get
away without being vaccinated because I think
they know they took a chance. I think secretly
they know if anybody pays any attention, they know
someone who's had a bad reaction to the vaccine.
Speaker 1: So this this really is wacky. Let's
go through it piece by piece, right? So first,
Joe Rogan says there's an artificial
shortage of the monoclonal antibodies.
If you research how the vaccines are made
and how the monoclonal antibodies are made
right now, there is a much more limited ability
to generate monoclonal antibodies for the same
number of people as vaccine doses have been made.
That's just a fact of production. So the first
thing is that there's an artificial shortage.
There is simply not the availability because of
the production process for monoclonal antibodies
versus vaccines widely documented. This stuff is
all out in the open. You can find it then, he
says. The monoclonal antibodies have it just
you just you just get rid of it. It just cures
you. We have randomized controlled trials with
monoclonal antibodies. They are efficacious.
It is not a silver bullet. It is not a silver
bullet. And if you are in a situation where you
need monoclonal antibodies, you are far better off
being vaccinated, so understand that the two first
claims there's an artificial shortage demonstrably
untrue. It simply kills COVID. Not true. It's
effective. It's an effective treatment. OK. Also,
by the way, then he goes into the financial.
He says There's a financial. It must be,
Jocko says. What's the point here? Why it's fine.
It is it financial. And Rogan says it must be.
The vaccines are made by far of pharmaceutical
companies, which make money from from vaccines,
the monoclonal antibodies are made by
pharmaceutical companies that make money
from monoclonal antibodies. This if you can't
ascribe a profit motive to one and not the other,
it's for profit pharmaceutical companies making
both. So it's a wacky claim to make. And in
addition to that? The vaccine, the Pfizer vaccine
is now fully approved by the FDA. The monoclonal
antibodies are authorized for emergency use when
when we say, well, we don't know. We really,
I mean, if you want to make that case, we now
know more from a from a regulatory standpoint
about the Pfizer vaccine than the monoclonal
antibodies, but that is missing. And then lastly,
you know, everybody vaccinated people
want the unvaccinated to get a vaccine
because they want others to take a risk the way
that that is crazy. That is crazy. There is no
evidence of that whatsoever, and everyone knows
someone who's had a bad reaction. I don't know
anyone who's had a bad reaction. I mean, I know
people who were like for 24 hours. I was, um,
my girlfriend's arm got red for a little while,
for like eight hours or something like that. I
don't I don't know anybody who's had really
a bat. So it's so silly. And unfortunately,
it's going over a line into something that
now is getting much more dangerous than,
you know, JFK or flatterer. Not that. Not
that Rogan believes all this stuff, but
some of this stuff is more
benign. This is very much not